someone should really explain to the
president that the things he says in
fundraising meetings and speeches even
if they're not televised might someday
become public and as a result of exactly
that Donald Trump has now been caught
red-handed admitting that he just makes
stuff up when he talks to world leaders
yesterday Donald Trump admitted during a
fundraising speech that he straight-up
made up information when meeting with
the Canadian Prime Minister Justin
Trudeau and when they met Trump said to
Justin Trudeau that the u.s. runs a
trade deficit with Canada and this is
all relative to the broader narrative
that Trump likes to put out there that
it's all very unfair for the US on trade
we have trade deficits with just
everybody of course it's not true and
Trump admitted that he said it not
knowing whether it was true or not when
I saw the headline Trump makes stuff up
when speaking with world leaders I
immediately thought oh yeah we know that
obviously Trump's making stuff up all
the time but no we now know specifically
of something that Trump said to Justin
Trudeau without having any idea whether
it was true here's the stunning
transcript from Donald Trump's
fundraising speech in Missouri to donors
where Trump said this is Trump telling
the story as per the Washington Post
Trudeau came to see me he's a good guy
Justin he said no no we have no trade
deficit with you we have none Donald
please Trump said mimicking Trudeau
according to audio of the private event
in Missouri obtained by The Washington
Post nice guy good looking guy comes in
Donald we have no trade deficit he's
very proud because everybody else you
know we're getting killed Trump goes on
to say so he's proud I said wrong Justin
you do I didn't even know I had no idea
I just said you're wrong and you know
why because we're so stupid and I
thought they were smart I said you're
wrong Justin he said nope we have a
trade deficit I said well in that case I
feel differently I said but I don't
believe it
I sent one of our guys out his guy my
guy they went out I said check because I
can't believe it well sir you're
actually right we had
no deficit but that doesn't include
energy and timber and when you do we
lose 17 billion dollars a year it's
incredible so first let me just
translate because the the parsing of
this stuff is pretty damn difficult
because of how Trump speaks what he's
saying is that without knowing the truth
about whether we have a trade deficit or
trade surplus with Canada Trump asserted
that we have a trade deficit then he
says he sent out one of his guys to
check it out and that the guy came back
and said you were right mr. president we
lose 17 billion a year in other words we
have a 17 billion a year trade deficit
to Canada now the most important thing
here is that it's not true the United
States actually has a trade surplus with
Canada not a deficit so on the facts I
don't think anybody in the audience is
going to be surprised the Donald Trump
said something that wasn't true but I
want to get to this sort of deliberate
lying and part of that in order to just
kind of show you the weirdness of what
what Trump says there's one other really
strange thing from the front fundraising
speech that caught my eye and it seems
like a total non sequitur by Trump
talking about a bowling ball test where
at a certain point during this speech
Donald Trump said it's the bowling ball
test they take a bowling ball from 20
feet up in the air and drop it on the
hood of the car Trump said of Japan if
the hood dents the car doesn't qualify
it's horrible he said it was unclear
what he was talking about I like that
the little add-in from the Washington
Post it was unclear what the president
was talking about sort of the mantra of
this is this administration and I would
love it actually if Trump is started
running around testing their cars by
dropping bowling balls on the hoods from
20 feet up I don't think that would go
particularly well I'm not even sure if
they'd be testing the cars they could be
testing the bowling balls instead yeah
who knows which is harder it's sort of
like diamond is the hardest but what
what stuff well I think that's the whole
point right to test the quality of the
car but you might have a really crappy
bowling ball it's a good point Wharton
should be ashamed of itself for having
admitted this man to its academic
program more embarrassment and you know
it there's the sort of like Trump's a
liar and that's bad side of this entire
thing but we can't expect the leaders of
our country
and of other countries too productively
work together if they can't even just
establish some basic facts knowable
facts right like does the United States
have a trade deficit or a trade surplus
with regard to Canada the level of
distrust that would be correct for other
countries to have when dealing with
Donald Trump is directly putting the
United States at a disadvantage and it
is an actual national security issue
because what you have increasingly our
circumstances where you can't trust
Donald Trump not to spill secrets from
our allies including what took place in
the Oval Office with Sergey kis lyac and
other Russians where Trump just spilled
the beans on things that Israel had told
us you can't trust Donald Trump to even
deal straight ahead on the facts even
just knowable economic data so we're not
gonna really be able to fix problems or
either or even garner respect from world
leaders around the world if this is what
Donald Trump is seen and understood to
be doing and it's horrible that he's
admitting it but I'm glad he's admitting
it okay okay I I was just gonna say I
feel as though it's one thing when he
lies to his lackeys yes because they're
working for him they're not gonna cross
him and go to the media and say
otherwise you know but these foreign
leaders they have their own interests at
heart so they're going to call him out
on a lie if they have to yeah although
for some reason it's not clear Trudeau
did call him out right then and there
but ultimately we did learn the truth
and I think that's really the most the
most important thing here
okay so Trump admits and almost really
brags like it's a really cool thing that
he was able to do he just lies to Justin
Trudeau as if that's kind of an
accomplishment in some way very backward
set of priorities that we're seeing here
today's episode of the David Pakman show
is made possible in part by brilliant
which is a great online service that
allows you to master concepts in math
science and engineering by solving fun
and challenging problems and unlike
other learning sites when I'm using
brilliant I'm learning by working
hands-on with real-world scenarios and
problems you solve challenging puzzles
that have been designed by expert
educators and professionals from all
over the world they don't move too fast
they don't move too slowly they take you
step-by-step through the topics you're
interested in at your own pace and one
of their principles is effective
learning is active watching YouTube
videos which is great by the way I
encourage it and I do it all the time
that's a more passive form of learning
that gets you so far
that's when brilliant comes in and
you're watching you're learning not by
watching but by actually doing and you
can get started right now at brilliant
org slash David Pakman first 200 to
visit the website brilliant org slash
David Pakman will get 20% off an annual
premium membership but of course sign up
for free at brilliant org slash David
Pakman